geht es ihnen auch so
das jahr zu ende und man fragt sich wo
die zeit geblieben ist was gut lief was
weniger und wofür sich eigentlich zu
leben lohnt herzlich willkommen zur
sternstunde philosophie zum
jahresabschluss in der ihr über diese
fragen nachdenken wollen
ich freue mich sehr dass mit anna-maria
zu tun während denken seit vielen jahren
um das gute sinnvolle leben kreist
herzlich willkommen frau pieper guten
tag vor beläuft
frau pieper sie haben ja von berufswegen
ganz viel über das gute sinnvolle leben
nachgedacht ist die frage für sie
eigentlich überhaupt noch eine wand
setzt sie sich machen wir noch hin und
denken darüber nach
ja ich denke selber drüber nach ich
werde aber oft angefragt etwas über das
gute leben zu berichten
und ich muss dann immer gleich bremsen
und sagen wie ich habe keine rezepte wie
das geht sondern man muss sich darüber
unterhalten um zu sehen wo es denn
hingehen soll und wie man wenn man
zurückblickt das beurteilt ich finde das
schon dessen zentrales thema der
philosophie allerdings eher den neueren
philosophie in der griechischen
tradition hat man ja eher nachgedacht
über den kosmos insgesamt also das
weltall und wie der mensch stand da
eingebettet ist und mit seinen
sehnsüchten das ist eine ganz andere
frage als wenn man das individuum in den
blick nehmen bis das denn für sie
persönlich ist der jahreswechsel für sie
ein spezieller moment ja im grunde
genommen schon das macht man doch dass
man schaut wie ist das jahr gelaufen ist
das rüber gekommen was ich mir
vorgenommen habe wo bin ich gescheitert
und warum und ist es schlimm
oder soll ich mir was neues vornehmen
für das kommende jahr
also ich glaube das ist natürlich was
anderes als was in der literatur oft
läuft unter lebensbilanz also jemand der
dem tode nahe ist und dann zurückblickt
hatte sich gelohnt mein leben das ist
eine etwas künstliche frage aber man
möchte doch eine antwort die darauf
hinausläuft dass man
ja ist es war nicht umsonst dass man da
waren es ist was rausgekommen dabei das
ist ja das eine dass es nicht umsonst
waren die andere frage die mich auch
immer wieder umtreibt ist lebe ich das
leben das ich eigentlich leben will und
wenn ich ihr leben anblicke und ihren
wer begangen dann bewundere ich daran
dass es immer wieder so überraschende
wendungen genommen hat zumindest für
mich von außen gesehen sie sind zum
beispiel die einzige professorin für
philosophie die ich kenne sie waren sehr
lange professorin für philosophie an der
universität basel
die ihren lehrstuhl frühzeitig
zurückgegeben hat sie haben mit 60
jahren gesagt das reicht uns waren eine
frühpensionierte philosophen professorin
jacob das ist nicht gerade sehr oft der
fall
die kollegen haben sich an den kopf
gefasst die verstehen das auch nicht
karriere heißt wie die und ich mama in
basel hätte es geheißen noch bis 70
jahre und das wäre für mich überhaupt
nicht infrage gekommen ich war relativ
früh habilitiert gerade über 30 und ich
fand dann insgesamt also 35 jahre uni
das ist mehr als genug es gibt auch noch
außerhalb der uni dinge die man machen
und erleben kann ich war gern
professoren aber als ich gegangen bin
war dieser umbruchzeit wo bologna aufkam
und die ganz neuen studien regeln und
ich habe gedacht unter so bedingungen
würde ich nicht studieren wollen haben
sie gar den schluss lange nachgedacht
oder ist das ja eigentlich schon ich
habe zwei jahre bevor ich dann 60 war
mit 58 offiziell gekündigt und damit ich
wollte das direkt angeschlossen an mich
nachfolgerin oder nachfolger da ist und
der rektor fand das sehr
also der war so irritiert und sagte
überlegen sie sich das doch noch mal ich
habe gesagt nein das ist für mich klar
mit 60 und bitte leiten sie alles in die
wege
damit den reibungslosen übergang ist sie
hat mir im vorgespräch auch gesagt jetzt
deutsch und deutlich sie hatten
schlichtweg die schnauze voll hat die
schnauze voll
aber das lag daran ich war lange zeit
die ersten zehn jahre in basel die
einzige frau wurde ihm sämtliche gremien
geschickt es hieß dann immer frau pieper
brauchen dringend
frau und in ermangelung anderer frauen
musste ich dann überall einsitz nehmen
und ich fand eigentlich war ich habe
mehr für die studierenden da und nicht
für alle möglichen gremien dann kam noch
die ethikkommissionen dazu und am
schluss habe ich tatsächlich nur noch in
solchen gremien gesessen und die
philosophie die ist so am rande mit
gedümpelt und das war mir zu wenig nun
haben alle gedacht na ja wenn sie jetzt
geht aus dem uni betrieb dann hat sie
zeit mehr für die kommission dabei wäre
es mir umgekehrt lief aber nein ich hab
so einen richtig harten schnitt gemacht
und dies ist die schnauze voll haben da
reden sie auch immer wieder darüber wenn
man ihnen zuhört wenn man auch sie schon
länger kennt dafür auch die akademische
philosophie zeit weil sie aus zu eng
empfunden haben ja dass ich etwas was
immer die begleitet hat und sie haben
einmal auch erzählt dass es viele
situationen gab dieses gerangel um
argumente auch in kommissionen das
gerangel und projekte was sie gesagt
haben das schien ihm manchmal so ganz
ähnlich in den berühmten sketch von
loriot wo sich zwei herren in einer
badewanne um die ente streiten da hat
sich ein herr in das falsche hotelzimmer
verirrt und der andere kommt hinzu der
rechtmäßige mieter des hotelzimmers
sozusagen um die beiden sitzen also in
der wanne und streiten sich
davon brauchen sie nicht mehr
unsere in szenerien aber das ist noch
halbwegs zivilisiert wie die miteinander
umgehen ich meine manchmal fliegen die
fetzen nicht dass sich die kollegen grad
geprügelt haben aber sozusagen dieses
gar nicht eingehen auf die wünsche des
anderen und immer sich einfühlen warum
auch der die ente ja man in gottes namen
so schlimm ist es ja auch nicht
aber ich finde das sehr typisch ja und
ist es auch typisch für die art und
weise wie philosophiert wurde der mann
ist die tradition der philosophie
anschaut sie haben sich ja viel auch mit
feministischer philosophie
auseinandergesetzt und mit einem
spezifisch weiblichen blick auf die
philosophie also das war bei mir relativ
spät ich bin einfach männlich zu zivil
an der universität ähnlich sozialisiert
worden weil es eigentlich ja nur männer
gab und ich die klassischen philosophen
so studiert hat mit der perspektive die
ich auch gelernt hat er im philosophie
unterricht und er sich in basel war als
die ersten weiblichen studenten kamen
sagten wir müssen uns mal damit
beschäftigen dann habe ich angefangen
judith butler zu lesen ist illegal und
wir sind die augen aufgegangen ich habe
kürzlich verstanden warum ich mit den
klassischen texten manchmal so mühe
hatte auch mit der argumentation form es
ist schon ein bestimmter blick auf die
dinge der anders ist als bei frauen
deutlich ist mir das geworden
als dann versucht wurde in der ethik
männliche und weibliche perspektive
durch eine kipp figur zu verdeutlichen
die kib figur man sieht ja nie beide
gleichzeitig den hasen oder grenze genau
sondern nicht diese sondern man muss den
sozusagen den blick wechseln damit man
die andere viel genau oder die beiden
gesichter und die sah ja das ist auch
ein gutes beispiel und das was daran
wichtig ist aus meiner sicht ist da ist
nicht die eine perspektive die besseren
und die andere die schlechtere
sondern sie sind beide gleichberechtigt
sozusagen in einem und das fand ich so
wichtig dieses wechseln von perspektiven
und das hat mir immer gefehlt das hat
sie ja dann auch wirklich beschäftigt
das gibt vor ihnen zum beispiel ein buch
über feministische ethik sie haben auch
ein buch geschrieben aufstand des
stillgelegten geschlechts dass ich als
student und damals gelesen habe in der
sie auch einführen in die feministische
ethik und ich erinnere mich auch sehr
gut an mein studium bei ihnen ich war
nämlich tatsächlich auch eine weile lang
bei ihnen studentin das wissen sie
vielleicht gar nicht mehr
aber interessant ein weiß ich für mich
jetzt als erinnerung war vor allem eine
szene und wirklich auch prägend für mich
da haben wir nämlich ein seminar gehabt
über existenz philosophie und wir
mussten einen text lesen von barry da
und ich habe wirklich nichts verstanden
ich saß zu hause und ich habe wirklich
gedacht ich bin einfach zu dumm für
diese art texte und ich komme dieses
seminar und wir haben diskutiert und
irgendwann begannen sie schallend zu
lachen und haben gesagt man versteht
hier kein wort wir gehen einen kaffee
trinken und das war's ja wunderbar für
mich ich habe ich immer wieder an ihr
lachen erinnert dieses auch sich darüber
hinwegsetzen und zu sagen es gibt eine
grenze dessen was ihr noch versuchen
müssen zu verstehen ja ja ich meine das
ist so ich gebe mir schon mühe
na ja das ist mir schon klar aber
irgendwo mache ich dann schluss streng
sei es bringt mir nichts nicht also wenn
jemand so redet und das als philosophie
verkauft was ich nicht nachvollziehen
kann dann interessiert es mich
irgendwann nicht mehr und der räder hat
schon texte den ich was abgewinnen
konnte aber manches fand ich so abstrus
dass ich dachte da müssen wir gar nicht
länger darüber nachdenken und so im lauf
der jahre bei auseinandersetzungen mit
kollegen auch in den gremien nebenher
ich war eigentlich immer vorgesehen auf
der position für die vermittelnden
zwischen den unterschiedlichen aber
dafür muss man erst mal verstehen was
jeder will dann habe ich gemerkt den
ging es meistens gar nicht ums
philosophische sondern um eine eigene
standortbestimmung ab in abgrenzung von
den kollegen und dann immer zugleich der
anspruch das ist die bessere
also dieses wertende moment dass man das
nicht gelten lässt dass jemand eine ganz
andere philosophie vertritt
das hat mich immer gestimmt die existenz
philosophie das wollte man jahrelang die
ohren gehauen das ist doch keine
philosophie
und ja und gerade über diese philosophie
wollten heute ja auch sprechen weil wir
haben mich ja eben die frage ins zentrum
gestellt haben wie gehen wir eigentlich
mit dieser sinnfrage um und gerade ihnen
am ende eines jahres was mache ich hier
eigentlich ist mein leben ein gutes
leben lebe ich das leben das ich leben
möchte
und sie haben schon gesagt die existenz
philosophie hat sie immer schon
beschäftigt schon sören kirche ja war
eigentlich die personen zu der sie ihre
doktorarbeit verfasst hat
später dann albert kam eine eine
wichtige figur für sie
sie haben mal gesagt von albert kamin
kann man unter anderem lernen dass man
in einem kreisförmigen modell über den
sinn des lebens nachdenken soll und ich
habe hier die beiden sachen mitgenommen
die meisten sagen sie denken linear
übrigen sinn des lebens nach also man
denkt sich irgendwann ist er und
überlegt oben ist der sinn und da muss
ich jetzt hin
währenddessen sie sagen der sinn des
lebens erschließt sich einem eigentlich
nur wenn wir im kreis sinn des lebens
denken sie sehen da lässt sich gar nicht
so gut zeichnen man muss da viele kreise
ziehen bis dahin sicher gibt vielleicht
könnte das ein bisschen genauer erklären
was meinen sie damit was heißt es sich
im kreis den sinn des lebens zu
erschließen
ja vielleicht ist das andere modell ganz
hilfreich was das nicht leistet das
lange jahre modell
sie haben jetzt die vertikale gezeigt
aber das lineare wird meistens in der
horizontale auch also ja als under
zeitschiene entlang nicht und die geht
ja ins unendliche
und wenn man da sich ein ziel setzt dann
kann das sein dass das irgendwie so weit
voraus in der zukunft ist dass man im
grunde genommen nie am ziel ankommt und
das ist das problem
ich meine es gibt so eine karikatur wo
jemand eine stange über der schulter hat
und da hängt ja was dran
die wurst villa haben nicht
aber die ist nicht erreichbar bis dann
jemanden mal hingeht und sagt dieses
ganze modell ist scheiße man anders
sehen und dann kommt man auch hd
programme also ein lineares modell an
der zeitschiene entlang oder 1 das in
die ideale es wäre nach oben geht
da kommt man im grunde nie an ein ziel
denn die sind endlos die linien nicht
und die kreis figur ist geschlossen das
heißt jeder ausgangspunkt ist zugleich
auch zielpunkt und daher kommt dann eben
auch diese behauptung das ziel der weg
ist das ziel
das heißt man macht dann nicht mehr in
einzelnen punkt auf der peripherie aus
und sagt so jetzt bin ich angekommen
sondern man sagt ich bin jetzt punktuell
angekommen wo ich hinwollte
aber es geht weiter und was man da
einschließt in den kreis das ist die
identität der einzelnen individuellen
personen die ihre geschichte an der
peripherie entlang erzählt und wenn sie
sie an der peripherie entlang erzählt
dann könnte man ja trotzdem noch
überlegen was ist eigentlich in der
mitte jeder kreis hat ja mittelpunkt ja
gibt es eine mitte dieser sind
geschichte ich würde sagen im zentrum
steht eben der sinn der sinn der immer
in irgendeiner form zwar benannt wird
aber zudem kommt man nicht hin man kommt
nur hin indem man den kreis abschreitet
und immer auf den sinn schaut und dann
der sinn denn können sie eigentlich kann
mich so einzeichnen
denn der ist gleichsam die wert
perspektive unter der man das gehen des
weges auf der kreis linie beurteilen und
dieses wert konstrukt gibt mir zugleich
auch immer antwort darauf ob der schritt
den ich jetzt getan habe richtig ist
oder ob ich weiter gehen nicht sie haben
ja verschiedene romane geschrieben
nachdem sie die universität verlassen
haben haben sie begonnen oder ohne zu
schreiben und ich möchte eine stelle aus
einem roman zu lesen dass der zweite
roman seyer
uns ausschreibungen ein krimi da gibt es
eine figur caro und die sagt vielleicht
bestand überhaupt die ganze lebenskunst
in nichts anderem als dem
verschwindenlassen von löchern die
aufgeführten die wörtern einen
gesamtkontext vortäuschten den es an
sich gar nicht gab
ohne den jedoch nur fragmente existieren
würden die nicht zueinander passten oder
die das jetzt erzählen mit dem kreis der
sind in der mitte wir kreisen um diesen
sinn wenn wir nicht so richtig sehen
aber erzählen dann geht es ja warum eben
diese löcher mit der zeit zu stopfen die
uns erzählen versteckt des jahres genau
und man kann das loch nicht ein für
allemal stopfen
das ist immer so die gängige vorstellung
von sinn so eine ganze cd die ein für
allemal festlegt was der sinn ist und
ich glaube man muss darüber nachdenken
ob der sinn nicht eine werdens kategorie
ist sozusagen also ich meine nehmen wir
ein anderes modell das von camille den
city fonds das ist auch ein kreis modell
der steigt immer den berg hinauf er weiß
darum dass der sinn nicht da oben liegt
die götter haben das verwehrt der stein
rollt ja immer zurück ins tal
und dieses auf und ab der sinnfindung
die überhaupt nicht möglich ist nach dem
modell der götter die durchbricht sie
sie fast in dem er sagt ich pro jetzt
hier jetzt meinen sinn in meinen weg und
jeder schritt den ich hier gehe der
gelingt mir obwohl ich dieses
fürchterliche ding von felsen der
mitschleppen muss aber ich habe jetzt
selbst mein leben bestimmt und lass
nicht mehr die götter darunter befinden
was für mich sozusagen ein gutes leben
ist verstehe ich sie richtig sie haben
ja auch viel über das absurde
nachgedacht und kamin ist ja einer der
denker des absurden dass sie sagen
würden man versteht kam nie falsch wenn
man sagen würde er hat gesagt dass sie
in hadersleben hat keinen sinn sondern
der würde sagen der sinn besteht darin
zu akzeptieren dass wir im kreis gehen
im kreis gehen im kreis denn das zentrum
nie sehen sondern eben immer nur umgehen
und damit irgendwie beginnen einen sinn
zu erschaffen
aber gut es gibt natürlich auch
man kann das modell auch negativ deuten
also absurd heißt ja widersinnig und er
sagt jan man geht von der erfahrung aus
dass das alltägliche leben von sich aus
keinen sinn bietet es ist immer das
gleiche derselbe langweilige ablauf ich
meine wir haben ja so ein triviales
modell dafür das hamsterrad wo einer
keine schöne vorstellung genau und wie
kann man den hamster dazu bringen dass
wir das für sinnvoll hält
machen sie ernst auf den hamster zu
trinken diarras hamster ich meine dieses
nehme an dass das rad wäre aller kam von
den göttern verordnet der hamster kann
also nur in diesem der kann da nicht
raus springen denn der muss sich
arrangieren mit den gegebenheiten die er
vorfindet
und dann kann nur sein ich verzweifle
dass das bringt nichts ich habe gar
keine eigene möglichkeit mein leben zu
bestimmen
oder aber er sagt sich jetzt gucke ich
mir das modell mal an wie das läuft und
was steckt da vom prinzip hinter und
kann ich sozusagen mit jeder umdrehung
irgendetwas für mich ausschlagen und das
ist ja wirklich typisch camille dieses
eigentlich dem leben trotzdem etwas
abtrotzen kann man fast schon sagen eine
andere haltung die zum beispiel bei
kirche ganz wichtig ist ist die ironie
und thomas ney klein ein philosoph der
auch diese ironie sehr stark gemacht hat
der sagt zb auch ironie ist eine
spezifisch menschliche lebenshaltung
nämlich immer sich in einer gewissen
kritischen distanz zu dieser sinn frage
zu befinden und das ganze auch
vielleicht nicht zu ernst zu nehmen sich
selber reflektieren zu können
also ich glaube das ist eigentlich die
these die hinter karikaturen steckt man
bildet die wirklichkeit ab aber in einer
verzerrten form die aber durch ihre
verzerrung dann zum lachen reizt und
dann ist man sozusagen in einer anderen
haltung gegenüber dem unerträglichen das
bleibt so unerträglich wie es ist
aber wenn man darüber lachen kann
dann hat man doch eine distanz gewonnen
und aus der distanz wird diese verzerrte
darstellung nicht plötzlich schön oder
gelingt in irgend einer ästhetischen
hinsicht aber sie belebt doch meine
fantasie und in der fantasie stelle ich
mir eine welt vor in der die
verzerrungen nicht da sind
und dann bin ich eigentlich sehr schnell
bei einer sinn vorstellung die mich
überlegen lässt was kann ich sozusagen
aus dem gegebenen noch ausschlagen an
möglichkeiten für mich die in richtung
sinn gehen der als ganze nicht
verwirklicht werden kann das heißt
selbst loriot wäre so was wie ein sim
produzent weil er diese kritische
distanz mit uns ein gibt sozusagen ja ja
finde ich also ich meine egal was man
auch die die ganzen masse die er immer
präsentiert und sagt ein leben ohne mops
ist möglich aber nicht sinnvoll
ich habe den selber mal erlebte vicco
von bülow der ist eigentlich ein ganz
ernster mann einer der gar nicht lacht
also auch in den filmen hoppenstedt oder
so wie er da auftritt linkisch einer der
über alles stolpert und der zeigt das
ganze leben wirft uns eigentlich nur
steine in den weg und trotzdem kann man
was draus machen indem man die anderen
zu teilhabern macht und sie dann darüber
lachen können
jetzt haben wir darüber gesprochen wie
viele theoretische abstraktion ist
vielleicht zu weinen braucht und diese
sinnfrage geben wie zu verstehen und
diese neben philosophin in ihrem roman
den ersten roman den sie geschrieben
haben die klugscheißer gmbh
da geht es um eine philosophische praxis
sie machen sich auch da eigentlich in
ironischer distanz ein bisschen ja
darüber lustig ja verkaufen klug heitz
rezepte die verkaufen den sinn des
lebens und so weiter man kann sich da
beraten lassen verdienen gutes geld
damit
und man fragt sich dann eigentlich auch
so ein bisschen was denken sie
eigentlich frau pieper kann man denn mit
philosophie überhaupt mehr lernen über
den see
oder ist das eigentlich so ein
klugscheißer idee eigentlich sind wir
philosophen überhaupt nicht geeignet da
über diesen sie nachzudenken sondern das
sind die menschen da draußen die ich
vielleicht alle diese klugen ideen gar
nicht machen
also ich denke mal was man lernen kann
durch philosophie ist eine kritische
distanz
das ist die ironie ja das ist die ironie
klar also ironische brechung dessen was
der fall ist und zugleich dadurch
gewinnt ein jahr ist dann immer eine
distanz vom sachverhalt und dann
versuchen daraus profit zu schlagen für
das eigene leben den misslingt das alles
das ist ja der großvater der sie als
klugscheißer abtut nicht und denkt der
ist zahnarzt der macht sowas ganz
handwerkliches und leute die meinen dass
sie mit dem kopf allein die menschheit
verbessern können
das funktioniert nicht mehr
aber ich glaube auch dass doch diese
mitglieder dieser praxis dazu da sind um
menschen dialog fähig zu machen
das ist nun zu einer zeit geschrieben
das buch da war das internet noch nicht
so ausgeprägt er heute quasseln die
menschen ja ständig nicht also sind ja
immer ständig in irgendwelchen
kommunikationen aber das ist alles
völlig oberflächlich das geht nicht auf
den grundmann man spricht ein problem an
und damit ist die sache schon getan und
ich denke philosophie hält dazu an
lösungen oder wege sich zu überlegen wie
man zu lösungen kommt und die sind nicht
verallgemeinern bar wenn ein individuum
in einer bestimmten situation eine
entscheidung treffen muss und das ist
glaube ich das was in der existenz
philosophie so interessant ist dass
gezeigt wird wie jemand zu einer
entscheidung kommt die er verantworten
muss und die zugleich aber sozusagen
eine wahl zwischen zwei übeln dann
stellt wir tun immer so wenn ich mich
entschieden habt das ist dann immer das
beste und was da herauskommt ist
sozusagen das ideal das ist
ja nicht wir leben ja in den tag und
meinen wir könnten alles lösen aber wir
sehen gar nicht dass immer zwischen zwei
übeln oder sagen wir mal meistens
zwischen zwei übeln gewählt werden muss
nicht so zeigen
ja weil es die ideale lösung nicht gibt
also der sinn bleibt da im zentrum den
kann ich nicht eins zu eins umsetzen
aber dann bieten sich verschiedene wege
an die ich gehen kann und keiner von dem
ich so ideal wie der sin mir das
vorgegaukelt hat und dann muss ich mich
für den weniger üblen weg entscheiden
aber die konsequenzen verantworten das
heißt der fehler besteht zum einen darin
dass man das perfekte sucht oder auch
schon nur das gute sucht und nicht
einsieht dass es immer eigentlich nicht
besonders gut ist was man als
wahlmöglichkeit naja ich meine das ist
einfach die theorie der klassischen
philosophen die stellen ideale aufsagen
auch die sind nicht erreichbar das sind
ja gedanken konstrukte an den soll man
sich orientieren gegeben in eine gewisse
hilfe wenn man entscheidungen zählen
muss aber sie sagen dann nicht dass das
was rauskommt immer weit zurück bleibt
hinter dem was man ich meine utopie
machen das nicht die die versuchen dann
eins zu eins umzusetzen das ideal
scheitern genauso nicht nächstes
trotzdem so ein bisschen zu negativ mir
vorzustellen was immer ich wähle sind
zwei übeln ein bild das mir jetzt näher
wäre ich bin gespannt was sie dazu sagen
ist dass mir bei diesen kreisförmigen
modell auch noch das gedicht in den sinn
kam von rainer maria rilke ich lebe mein
leben in wachsenden irgendeinen das mir
sehr sehr lieb ist ja und da gibt es ja
auch diese diesem moment in dem dann
steht den letzten werde ich vielleicht
nicht vollbringen mama versuchen will
ich ihr könnt ihr das leben nicht auch
in erster linie einfach ein versuch sein
eine annäherung
sie haben völlig recht also ich meine
dieses übel bild kommt ja nur davon wenn
ich mich auf den standpunkt des sin
mittelpunktes stelle
von daher ist alles ja nicht ideal was
an der peripherie geschrieben ich muss
das am besten dem ideal entsprechende
aussuchen
aber trial & error ist auch im
wirklichen leben ganz wichtig und ein
versuch dann etwas umzusetzen von dem
man von vornherein weiß ich kann das
absolut gute überhaupt nicht umsetzen
dann mache ich ja schon abstrich und
sucht dann aber was kommt denn dem am
nächsten und mache nicht den fehler den
viele andere machen dass sich dann etwas
bestimmtes verabsolutieren und das
fanatisch verteidige und sage nur so und
nicht anders
und dann die anderen versuche zu
manipulieren in diese richtung zu gehen
könnte man sagen insofern ist die
existenz philosophie auch eine
philosophie der bescheidenheit ja ja
natürlich dass sich zurücknehmen und
auch zugleich einen philosophieren über
grenzen und das sind grenzen die wir uns
in freiheit und durch die freiheit
setzen das ist nämlich das positive
daran wenn sie sich an den beiden übeln
gestoßen haben
aber man muss sehen ich nehme an ganz
ganz schlechtes beispiel verkehrsregeln
ich bin verdammt jetzt dazu dass sich
immer rechts waren muss zumindest
wöchentlich in england auto fahre ich
darf keine einbahnstraße nicht mit 100
kilometern in entgegengesetzter richtung
durchfahren
wir haben uns einmal regeln gesetzt die
sichern sollten dass alle die am verkehr
beteiligt sind sicher da durchkommen
und wenn die regeln am agenten das haben
wir aus freiheit getan solche und solche
regeln haben darüber geredet was ist
vernünftig ist hier im kreisel gut und
zum wort aber wenn die regeln einmal
dahin müssen wir uns daran halten sie
sind sozusagen ein zwang sie sind das
kleinere übel gegenüber meiner
vorstellung einer absoluten freiheit ich
kann beliebig auto war aber man sagt ja
oft in unserer zeit ist genau das
problem nicht dass die regeln zu
erwehren sondern dass wir zu viel
freiheit haben menschen können ja
unglaublich viel heute entscheiden wenn
jetzt zum beispiel eine junge person
vielleicht nehmen die sich entscheiden
muss mache ich noch eine weitere
ausbildung binde ich mich an eine person
sätzlich eigene kinder in die welt gehe
ich ins ausland da ist es ja nicht so
dass die entscheidungs last dadurch
entsteht dass man denkt ich habe nur
zwei übel statt 27 sondern das gefühl
von ich weiß gar nicht wo anfangen es
ist so eine unglaubliche fülle an
möglichkeiten die wir belastet aber ich
glaube dass ein missverständnis von
freiheit eigentlich freiheit stellen wir
uns immer vor als grenzenlose
wahlmöglichkeiten und das erste was man
lernen muss auch als kind ist dass
freiheit etwas ist das ich immer auch im
kontext mit anderen freiheiten sehen
muss ich muss ganz schnell mit meinem
freiheits begehren an die grenzen der
freiheit der anderen an und diese
grundsätzlichen möglichkeiten reduzieren
sich dann doch ganz schnell die habe ich
natürlich aber irgendwo wenn ich dann an
die umsetzung denke und alles mit
bedenken wer betroffen ist durch meine
entscheidung
dann reduziert sich das wie gesagt auf
vielleicht vier oder fünf möglichkeiten
und dann suche ich da aus also ich
glaube freiheit kann man tatsächlich
nicht von verantwortung trennen
und was ich auch interessant in dieser
freiheitsbegriff der zeigt ja auch eben
wir können uns überhaupt wieder reflexiv
dass ich dieses grund philosophische ins
verhältnis setzen in ihrem neuesten
roman nehmen ich frag nicht wo die
blumen sind da gibt es einen moment den
fand ich sehr rührend was da steht ein
kleiner junge am meer und die gischt
spritzt ihm ins gesicht und der junge
fragt sich warum spuckt mich das mehr an
und dann merkt er dass mehr kann ja
nicht spucken war das mehr kann sich
nicht entscheiden ich aber kein
entscheidendes stück ich zurück oder
nicht diese erfahrung der freiheit prägt
diese hauptfigur ja das heißt da ist ja
auch die freiheit wir können uns
verhalten wie sie nicht einfach eine
naturgewalt
ja und das zeigt sich ja in der
auseinandersetzung jetzt ist das nicht
mit einem anderen menschen sondern mit
einer naturgewalt dass man doch
einschätzen kann was man trotzdem kann
so ein mächtiges gewässer eigentlich bin
ich da völlig hilflos
ein riesenberg ich meine bei nietzsche
gibt es zb auch der mensch über mensch
ist ja oft missverstanden worden nicht
als wäre das eine eigene gattung mensch
über mensch aber wie zu bringt so ein
beispiel
der mensch kann auf berge steigen er war
ja oft in sils maria und man weiß ja was
dafür hohe berge drum rum sind und wenn
der mensch auf dem gipfel steht überragt
er noch den größten berg um eine
menschenmenge das ist also so der berg
kann nicht mehr wachsen der der droid
sozusagen auf dem boden da ist ja ein
riesiges sowie das meer etwas das mich
wahnsinnig beeindruckt aber ich kann
mehr als dieser natur erscheinen die
mich eigentlich erdrückt und insofern
ist dieses mehr einmal an distanz gingen
zu diesem objekt und zugleich ein
ausloten dessen wie gehe ich damit um
zwischen schon zu einem verschwinden
oder messe ich mich damit uns dadurch
wird mir bewusst was meine freiheit kann
jetzt wenn wir noch einmal zu dieser
situation zurück kommen am ende des
jahres auf sein leben zurückblicken dann
haben jetzt darüber gesprochen wie man
vielleicht sich dem sinn annähern könnte
wie man über die optionen nachdenkt mama
kriegt man aber auch einfach schiere
panik man hat große augen
weil man zum beispiel denkt man
vergeudet sein leben oder weil man denkt
es gibt lauter abgründe um mich herum
ist die angst eine produktive kraft der
philosophie
also wenn es eine lähmende angst ist
sich ja nicht weil eine lähmende angst
hindert mich daran überhaupt etwas zu
tun dann werde ich bewegungsunfähig aber
ich kann mir doch eine positive form von
angst vorstellen die mich dazu bringt
die situation genauer zu betrachten und
sozusagen nach kleinen türchen zu suchen
wo ich eine ausflucht habe wenn das
nicht gelingen würde
dann wäre man wirklich arm dran aber ich
glaube angst ist eine grund
befindlichkeit die wichtig ist auch für
die eigene sicherheit die aber zugleich
den blick schärfen soll für das was
möglich ist
ich habe einmal über sie gelesen das hat
mich sehr berührt die sie erzählt haben
von ihrer frühen kindheit wie sie im
zerbombten berlin waren 1945 bei
kriegsende in einem keller glaube ich es
gab ein spalt in der mauer und ihre
mutter hat sie aus der jähriges mädchen
auf die straße gehoben und sie gebeten
hilfe zu holen und wie sie in diesen
straßen standen alles zerstört viel
elend war das eine erfahrung von angst
und habe diese brüchigkeit des kindes
dass dieses kriegsende erlebt und diese
ganzen schwierigen zeiten etwas was sie
auch jeden wie philosophisch geprägt hat
das kann ich jetzt schwer beurteilen ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob ich wirklich
angst hatte als als in dem alter kann
man eine situation gar nicht mit der
perspektive eines erwachsenen menschen
wahrnehmen
ich kann mich noch erinnern dass da eben
füße
menschen die die zerstört waren
herumlagen dass die ganze straße kaputt
war das habe ich auch berichtet dann
nach unten
niemand da alles tot wo sollte ich denn
da hilfe finden nicht aber ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie viel man rückwärts dann
da hinein interpretiert in so einer
situation aber ich sage mir wenn ich
mich ich kann mich dann noch gut daran
erinnern
dann war es doch etwas was mich sehr
beeindruckt hat und das ganze
kriegsgeschehen immer man musste hin und
her und die dauernd in den keller weil
die serien den ganzen tag gehen und das
ist natürlich was geblieben ist auch
heute noch ich kann keine sirene hören
ohne dass der drang da ist sofort unter
tisch zu verschwinden das gab es vorher
angekündigt wurde das ist nur probealarm
aber ich muss selber irgendwie nicht
lachen aber es ist tatsächlich so dass
man da doch dass da etwas
hängengeblieben ist von einer grundangst
die aber auch die angst der mutter
vielleicht war die ihre kinder schnell
und herren arm nahmen wieder runter in
keller und so das empfindet man ja als
kind mit nicht und das überträgt sich
dann und das war ja auch eine zeit in
der sie ich weiß nicht ob denen das
einfach in die wiege gelegt worden ist
oder ob sie das lernen musste in der sie
auch ihre kraft sozusagen ausprobieren
müssten sie haben auch darüber berichtet
wie sie ohne vater aufgewachsen sind ihr
vater ist gefallen in kriegen wie sie in
der schule dann zum teil so ein bisschen
bemitleidet worden sind ohne vater zu
sein und man in ihrem beispiel auch die
schulbücher geschenkt hat weil sie auch
nicht viel geld hatten
da gab es wohl eine szene wo sie die
bücher auf den boden geknallt haben ja
als ich das irgendwie demütigend fahren
ja ich bin ziemlich gemobbt worden so
würde ich das heute ausdrückt nicht auch
von den mitschülern die hatten halt
glück die väter waren aus dem krieg
zurück gekommen und das war ein makel
dass man da also zu hause nur eine
mutter hatte und ich habe eine sehr
starke mutter gehabt also da die hat
wirklich dann den vater mit ersetzt aber
dass man sozusagen die lehrer die finde
ich heute noch unmöglich dass man
ein kind vor der klasse denunziert und
sagt ich kann das nicht selber bezahlen
so als hätten sie es aus eigener tasche
gezahlt nicht also stellen wir das
kostenlos zur verfügung
das habe ich tatsächlich als demütigung
empfunden und jahre danach bin ich auch
nicht zu klassentreffen gegangen jetzt
gehe ich seit zehn jahren wieder ich bin
also ja es ist komisch ich meine aus
meinem mitschülerinnen ist aus allen was
geworden sind alles ärztinnen
juristinnen und lehrerinnen
es ist wirklich toll wir waren sehr
große klasse und wir verstehen uns heute
blenden und dem ist das auch nicht ganz
so bewusst ich habe gemerkt wir haben
alle gelitten unter diesen lehren die
man echt unmöglichen aber heute können
wir uns darüber unterhalten und sagen
okay
manches hätte anders gehen müssen aber
wenn ich an die zeit selber zurück denke
also schule dass dieses mal nicht es
hätte anders gehen können oder müssen
das beschäftigt mich manchmal auch wie
blicken dir denn eigentlich auf ein
leben als wenn ich in diesen kreis
ausgehen wenn die sie anschauen das
leben das sie bis jetzt geführt haben
sind sie natürlich auch eine person die
von vielen sehr viel bewunderung erfährt
gerade auch von zb frauen in der
philosophie sie würden eben sehr früh
haben sie wirklich daran festgehalten
sich zu habilitieren in der philosophie
sie wollten gerne eine professur mussten
lange warten
als frau auch in vielen warteschleifen
hat man sie vertröstet zwar wenig die
zeit in der eine frau schon eine
professur kriegen konnte aber es hat
dann geklappt und sie haben sich durch
alle diese ehrungen und wirrungen
behauptet und mit 60 dann trotzdem
gesagt neue professur brauche ich jetzt
nicht mehr schreiben sie ihre marne wenn
sie selber ihr leben betrachten wie viel
haben sie entschieden und wie viel
würden sie sagen ich hatte glück oder
das war ich bin ein charakter dass ich
mich da so behaupten konnte ich glaube
es lag einfach daran dass ich immer
neben plan a plan b plans lande ich
hatte immer
weil ich relativ jungen dran war mit all
diesen examens geschichten
ich hatte immer wenn das nicht klappt
mache ich was anderes
also ich war nicht so fixiert auf diese
eine karriere und das fand ich immer
sehr schwierig auch an meinen kollegen
die derart festgelegt waren daraufhin
oft erst mit 40 jahr überhaupt in den
universitären gremien berücksichtigt
worden
man sollte sich nicht festlegen es gibt
so viele dinge die man machen kann die
auch gut sind es hätte das gar nicht
sein müssen
aber als es sich dann ergab ja natürlich
aber bitte in basel das hat vier jahre
gedauert bis die mich gerufen haben
da hatte ich längst vergessen dass ich
mich da und und dann war das auch etwas
noch eine schwierige lage weil das alles
so patriarchal noch traditionell man
staaten ging also es ging beim
einkleiden kleidungen an also jeans das
ging gar nicht in der sitzung
und da war ich nun stur also ich hab
einfach dinge von denen ich dachte ja
das macht mir nichts aus dass da kann
ich denn entgegen kommt aber da wo ich
fand das ist jetzt wieder spricht
sozusagen meiner art wie ich lebe da
habe ich nicht nachgegeben
aber ich erinnere mich genau ein jahr
nachdem ich da war hat meine damalige
assistentin sich erkundigt
bei einem condomi professor prägen sie
sich immer auch so auf über die kleider
von der vp-nahen jetzt ruhig nackt in
die sitzung
das macht uns nichts mehr also ich meine
die haben sich auch an nicht gewöhnen
müssen nicht das muss ich dazu sagen in
münchen waren wir 30 philosophen da war
ich der dreißigste man in der gruppe
dass das ist irgendwie die haben mich
das gar nicht spüren lassen ich habe das
auch nicht irgendwie reklamiert dass ich
da die einzige frau war aber in basel
ist es schwierig in so einem großen
pakets gremium lauter oder überwiegend
weiße als männer so abfällig sagt da
sich so zu behaupten nicht und dieses
sich behaupten da gab es ja auch eine
figur die sie da auch ein stück weit ein
bisschen geprägt hat nämlich die chance
die vorsitzende der karl jaspers
gesellschaft sie hat sie da auch mit
hinein genommen
sein herz ist eine philosophin die man
gar nicht so gut kennt in der
deutschschweiz eine genfer philosophie
die auch professorin für philosophie war
in genf lagen ja auch präsidentin bei
der unesco in paris oder die rektorin
und diese schauen herrscht die hatte ja
wirklich auch etwas sehr aufmüpfiges die
war immer gegen den strom die hat zum
beispiel in der während der 68er unruhen
hat sich auf die seite der autoritären
erziehung geschlagen sie hat sich mit
ihrer partei mit der sp verkracht als es
um die liberalisierung in der
drogenpolitik dir genau sie haben mal
gesagt ein weiblicher sokratis für sie
also es war eine großartige frau muss
ich schon sagen sowas von unerschrocken
wie die festgehalten hat an ihren
prinzipien aber immer bereit zuzuhören
und manches zu revidieren wenn sie
plötzlich merkte da war etwas was ich so
nicht gesehen hatte aber sie war
schülerin von karl jaspers jaspers war
ja sehr krank der hat ja auch fürs volk
geschrieben über die atombombe und alles
was damals so anstand auch an aktuellen
fragen aber er war wegen seiner
krankheit nicht so viel unterwegs
während die scham herrschte ist hängen
gegangen
in alle möglichen bereiche wo sie bis
hin zum militär die sie eingeladen haben
wo sie dann den soldaten vorträge über
ethik gehalten hat und und das fand ich
so bewundernswert sich also so
ausdrücken zu können ich meinen ihre
muttersprache französisch
das deutsch was ich sprach klang ein
bisschen hat aber war vorzüglich höre
mir doch ganz kurz zu ich habe nämlich
etwas gefunden wo sie genau darüber
spricht nämlich über die intellektuelle
ehrlichkeit weil sie gesagt hat
philosophie muss immer verständlich
seien ja ich glaube es gehört zur
intellektuellen ehrlichkeit so klar zu
sein wie du möglich ich schätze die
absichtliche dunkelheit keineswegs also
versuche ich klar zu sprechen und ich
habe auch einen glauben an jeden
menschen eine hoffnung an jedem menschen
das heißt ich würde nie von vornherein
annehmen dass der hund der mensch
unfähig ist mich zu verstehen
eigentlich kommt es darauf an dass sich
die mittel finde das so klar zu sagen
dass er es versteht
haben sie das auch einen glauben an
jeden menschen verstehen zu koennen
also das hat sich etwas relativiert ich
habe zeitweise seminare gemacht für
pensionierte die zwei jahre vor der
pensionierung standen die wurden
aufgeklärt über ahv über testament
machen und so was alles in einem letzten
tag kann die sinnfrage für die war ich
zu stellen war vorher wahrscheinlich
immer der pfarrer gewesen
und da habe ich festgestellt dass es
sehr schwierig ist vor einem publikum zu
sprechen wo vom auto chauffeur bis zum
akademiker vor ihnen sitzt
ich habe immer so einen mittleren sprach
level für ein publikum
aber mit dass das funktioniert dann
nicht wenn der eine sich da irgendwo
nicht genügend beachtet fühlen der
andere sagt das geht schon über das
hinaus was ich verstehen kann
also ich frag vorher immer wenn ich für
im vortrag an gefragt werde was sind das
für leute ist es so genanntes
bildungsbürgertum da kann man auch
durchaus anspruchsvoll reden aber so ein
gemischtes publikum ist ganz schwierig
es lustig ich habe diesen herrscht auch
so verstanden dass es nicht nur darum
geht ist die philosophie so dass sie
jeder verstehen kann und wie kann hier
über philosophie sprechen dass jeder
verstehen kann sondern auch jeder mensch
an sich ist überhaupt in der lage zu
verstehen und habe dann nicht gefragt
ist das problem unserer zeit vielleicht
gar nicht so sehr die frage ob jeder
verstehen kann sondern sehr viel mehr ob
jeder verstehen will ja ja ich meine wer
verstehen will ist ja bereit einzugehen
auf das was sein gegenüber sagt und
zumindest mal probeweise die gedanken
für sich in anspruch zu nehmen
aber wer nicht verstehen will der ist
irgendwie fanatisch festgelegt auf etwas
und ich meine man muss bedenken die
geherrscht die hat in jüngeren jahren
für die sp die ganze programme gemacht
da durfte sie aber noch nicht mal wählen
also dass das war ich habe manchmal
hinterher gedacht wie geht das
eigentlich nicht man steht da nach einer
partei macht die programme für die aber
hat überhaupt keine möglichkeit sich
selber nun wenigstens stimmenmäßig mit
einzubringen
also von daher glaube ich ist es immer
doch wichtig zu sehen wie die
philosophie sich einbringen kann in den
öffentlichen diskurs und das galt lange
als verpönt und habe meinen kollegen die
haben sich immer furchtbar aufgeregt
nicht bis dann so nach und nach man in
den ethikkommissionen willkommen war in
allen möglichen anderen gremien auch wo
es um alltägliches ging nicht nur
politische gremien aber ursprünglich
wollten die philosophen im
im elfenbeinturm bleiben und den diskurs
nur untereinander pflegen und sich nicht
gedanken machen wie mache ich mich
verständlich leuten die eigentlich
interesse haben an philosophie aber
nicht das nötige instrumentarium
mitbringen und die wollen ja das hat
sich gezeigt als jostein gaarder sofies
welt kam was war das für ein
riesenerfolg
ich fand dass irgendwo nicht so toll
nicht also man die briefe aus dem
briefkasten mit den fragen und so und
manches ging über die köpfe auch völlig
weg aber die leute waren fasziniert und
das hat mir doch sehr zu denken gegeben
dass man philosophie auch einem
breiteren publikum war das haben sie
auch immer gemacht mit ihren
philosophischen cafés sie waren ja auch
gastmoderatoren bei der sternstunde für
eine weile lang war das auch der
bewegungen dann irgendwann zu sagen ich
mache jetzt nicht mehr akademische
philosophie sondern ich schreibe romane
nein das hat einen anderen grund ich
habe mit literaturwissenschaft
angefangen zu studieren das war
eigentlich mein ziel gewesen er
literaturwissenschaft und am schluss
dann halt entweder medien wie sie damals
noch ganz klein im verhältnis heute
waren oder halt in einem verlag
inspektorat gehen und ich hatte auch
angefangen zu promovieren in anglistik
ich habe anglistik und germanistik
studiert musste aber eine
zwischenprüfung machen in philosophie
bin dann zum ersten mal mit philosophie
in berührung gekommen
da hatte ich schon mal ein halbes
studium absolviert und da bin ich
irgendwie hängen geblieben obwohl ich
nichts verstanden
ich fand das unmöglich was die
professoren da
in der police um foto la toya dass sein
dass sein
die sind doch verrückt als tollste war
der assistent damals dieses professors
der machte ein fichte seminare
einführung und hat eine stunde lang über
den satz geredet dass ich setzt sich ich
habe das total bekloppt gefunden ja so
als als normalverbraucher hört man ja
nicht raus hat das gemeint ist mein
positioniert sich ganz sich ab gegen
anderes nicht ich hoffe es und so heute
kann ich das verstehen
damals habe die philosophie ist mich
mein ding und deswegen konnten sie dann
eben auch im seminar batterie da lachen
und haben mir sonst das philosophieren
wieder zurück geschenkt können ja ich
finde es ganz wichtig dass man auch das
alles nicht zu ernst nehmen
noch einmal zurück zur angst und furcht
hier kann man natürlich auch der höheren
kirche gar noch einmal in den sinn und
den lenders was ihr jetzt noch nicht
gesprochen haben ist ein anderer umgang
mit der sinnfrage mit dieser
existenziellen angst auch die man
empfinden kann wäre natürlich der glaube
ja kaum lehnen das ab der gläubiger
macht für ihn einen fehler das ist
eigentlich ein sprung aus dem absurden
raus eine billige hoffnung ein trost
denn haben hielt sie haben sich immer
wieder auch jetzt garmin jünger zeit
sehr intensiv mit der gabe von er ist
das für sie eine lösung
nein ich für mich war das immer der
kontrahent an dem ich sozusagen meine
nichtreligiösen argumente gesetzt habe
und ich fand ich fand ihn wirklich einen
ernst zu nehmenden partner in diesem
gespräch
aber man hat immer geschlagen für den
ästhetik er hat ja ästhetiker ethiker
und dann religiöser oder kristall diese
drei formen von sich verhalten und
orientieren im leben und der ästhetiker
der an genussmensch ist der aber
sozusagen aus der perspektive des täters
runtergemacht wird einer der nur
sozusagen das große fressen denkt an sex
und an solche dinge aber ästhetik geht
für mich viel weiter also
die fantasie wird stärker berücksichtigt
das schöne das was im leben sozusagen
eigentlich das überflüssige ist aber
doch ganz entscheidend dafür dass man
dieses leben genießen kann und deswegen
habe ich diese figur eigentlich immer
sehr viel mehr ab gewonnen
der gläubige christ das wird dann
wahnsinnig anstrengend bei ihm zu lesen
weil das eigentlich nur eine tortur ist
bis man das schafft christ zu werden und
ich hab es dann bis zur sokratischen
position gebracht wo man akzeptiert da
ist so etwas religiöses etwas gott
ähnliches aber das muss nicht der
christliche gott sein sondern es geht so
ein bisschen in die richtung wie jasper
ist das auch gemacht hat erklärt den
offenbarungseid abgelehnt aber dafür
gesagt okay in dieser transzendenz in
dem was das diesseits sozusagen
übersteigt gibt es begriffe wie gott und
dem entspricht auch etwas im diesseits
aber nicht dieser personalie gott und
wenn sie sagen ästhetik und diese
ästhetische mensch pakete gar nicht ja
auch diese ästhetische erfahrung für
viele eine erfahrung der transzendenz ja
also dieses gefühl von ich sehe die
naturgewalt und das berührt mich in
einer art und weise dass ich eine quasi
transzendentale erfahrung mache ja ja
also ich finde wenn man in diesem weiten
sehen wir jetzt ästhetik definiert also
nicht nur aus der ethischen perspektive
ein bisschen abfällig dann drüber redet
sondern ihr ein eigenes gewicht gibt und
ich habe immer für mich war das immer
weil sie so gerne in bildhaften
elementen denken
ich habe immer das kaleidoskop genommen
da stecken ja drei griechische begriffe
drin carlos eidos und scorpio also ich
sehe etwas ideelles und das ist schön
und wenn sie sich so ein kaleidoskop ist
es überhaupt nicht schön die paar
glasscheiben die da hinten bringen sie
durch gucken und das verlangen kann sie
nicht teilen
und was auch immer für musik bilder und
dieses kaleidoskop das war für mich
eigentlich immer etwas das sollte man
internalisieren diese aspekte
man sieht auch dass wenig schöne also
die glasscherben die die empirie die
eben auch wenn man das passieren würde
dann wären es nur sterben ja und auch
die idee ist für sich gar nichts wenn
ich die idee nicht umsetze dann sehe ich
auch nix aber so diese drei dinge
zusammenzubringen
das finde ich eigentlich eine
faszinierende vorstellung um so etwas
wie ganzheitlichkeit in den menschen zu
bringen
jetzt mag für einige vielleicht
überraschend sein wenn sie diese drei
figuren von kirkegaard zusammen erwähnt
haben dass sie sich für den ästhetischen
menschen entschieden haben weil man ja
auch weiß sie sind ja auch ethikerin was
denn mit dem mit dem richtigen leben
sagen wir mal diese spannung gibt es ja
immer wieder zwischen der ästhetik das
was mir gefällt vielleicht auch das
schöne designerkleid gegenüber der
ethischen lebenseinstellungen sich zu
fragen darf ich das jetzt kaufen ist das
korrekt produziert worden und so weiter
diese spannung gibt es ja heute extrem
ja das ist völlig richtig war den
ethiker als figur beikircher
todlangweilig vielleicht manchmal nicht
wieder der heiratet und ja das ist gut
wenn man das macht finde ich alles okay
nicht aber das war nicht das was sich
erstrebenswert finde aber was jetzt
sagen wir sind heute sehr schnell mit
der moralkeule da wenn wir auf leute
treffen die eine position vertreten die
wir nicht als die unsere anerkennen
nicht die fleischfressenden pflanzen und
sofort also egal oder eben kleiner und
so fort ich glaube man sollte aber
respektieren was jemand für sich für gut
hält und so lange man nicht in konflikt
kommt mit anderen sehe ich da auch kein
problem
natürlich kann man reden und sagen
was du da jetzt machst das hat so und so
viel co2 probleme nach sich
und dann kommt muscle als gm dafür spare
ich da und da nicht ich war kein auto
aber ich war velo und das kompensiert
das dann also ich finde wichtig dass man
sich gedanken machen und darüber
bescheid weiß und und dann wenn man
sozusagen über die stränge haut auch
weiß dass man das tut eine frage zum
schluss frau pieper wir haben gesagt das
ist eine sendung zum jahresschluss wir
blicken zurück natürlich blicken ganz
viele auch nach vorne und machen sich
vorsätze ich will es nicht einfach
fragen machen sie sich vor setzt ist
aber nicht frage sie ist es eigentlich
sinnvoll sich vorsätze zu machen sich
ziele zu stecken
dass sich sicher sinnvoll nur man sollte
augenmaß dabei waren meistens nimmt man
sich viel zu viel vor und dann ist man
am schluss des jahres enttäuscht dass
man nur 30 prozent wenn überhaupt hat in
die tat umsetzen können aber vorsätze
braucht man glaube ich auch um sich zu
motivieren
im jahr ist zu ende naja wie immer es
war aber jetzt kommt was los ist jetzt
kann ich wieder noch mal neu starten
diesen jenes unternehmen und doch finde
ich eigentlich eine wichtige sache
ich nehme mir nur noch dinge nur noch
vor zu reduzieren
wir sind alles etwas zu viel geworden
aber das finde ich dann auch wieder
erlaubt weil ich sage dann mache ich das
was ich dann mache ein bisschen
gründlicher mehr am schreibtisch sitzt
nicht mehr dauernd irgendwo im zug oder
wo und also ich finde das völlig in
ordnung vorsätze braucht man weil die
auch zeigen man ist immer noch voll im
leben drin hat mich schon irgendwo
abgeschlossen
ich mache das was ich mache etwas
gründlicher dass sie nicht einen sehr
schönen gedanken zu vertiefen das was
man eigentlich gerne tut und das bevor
man denkt es geht im leben eigentlich
darum ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich frau
pieper vier jahre ich bedanke mich mal
insel nächste woche sehen sie hier eine
kurzfassung der sternstunde der nacht
zum thema doppel leben eine herzliche
einladung zum spiel mit verschiedenen
identitäten 2009 10 war auch das jahr
von mirjam kam mit 70 jahren ist die
schweizer künstlerin so erfolgreich wie
nie zuvor
die sternstunde kunst hat sie ein jahr
lang begleitet das ergebnis gleich im
anschluss unser sternstunden jahr geht
damit zu ende
zeit für mich ihnen ganz herzlich zu
danken für interesse ihre treue mit
denken alles gute im neuen jahr waren
sie ein paar neue gedanken
bis bald
[Musik]